Speaker 1: Yesterday, we talked on the podcast
about how at this early stage, I mean,
listen, it's not even an early stage.
We're not even at the 2024 primary season.
We're not even beyond the 2022 primaries.
There have been some Republicans that are already
endorsing Donald Trump, Jim Jordan, for example.
We have also seen some Republicans declare they
will not support Donald Trump even if he does run.
This is starting to get even weirder because
Donald Trump has now signaled that he is running
in 2024. In a bizarre truth social post in which
he referred to himself as the future president of
the United States seems very clearly to be saying,
I'm running. Let's review this bizarre post. Trump
writing quote Why would a future president of the
United States want to have candid and important
conversations with his White House counsel if he
thought there was even a small chance that this
person, essentially acting as a lawyer for the
country, may someday be brought before a partizan
and openly hostile committee in Congress, or even
a fair and reasonable committee to reveal the
inner secrets of foreign policy or other important
matters so bad for the U.S.A.. Trump really a
legend in his own mind. So what is he talking
about? I know you might see this and say that's
like a verbal inkblot that what is that? Trump is
referring to his former White House counsel, Pat
Cipollone, which I last week was pronouncing. Chip
Maloney People very politely corrected me and they
said it is actually only pronounced Cipollone.
Speaker 2: No more drop.
Speaker 1: Exactly. We all make it. We all
make mistakes. So Trump here is saying, listen,
this was the lawyer for the country. But that is
a fundamental misunderstanding. The White House
counsel is the president's lawyer. Now, in an
ideal world, the president's interests are aligned
with the country's interests. In particular,
when Donald Trump was president. The country's
interests and Trump interests were completely at
odds. They were not in any way aligned. And so the
idea that Pat Cipollone, by representing President
Trump is representing the interests of the country
is nonsense. Now, the other thing is that he
wasn't having the conversation. So he says,
as a me, as a future president, I'm
disincentivized from talking to my lawyer if
I think my lawyer might someday be dragged before
a committee. Trump's conversations with Cipollone
when Trump was president were not conversations
as a future president. If that was the case,
you might be able to make a stronger argument that
they are protected by attorney client privilege.
CIPOLLONE He can't be forced to testify. We
wouldn't even be having this discussion. Trump
was the president. Cipollone represented him. They
were actively engaged in inciting a riot, trying
to overturn an election. Trump lost all these
different things. And of course, Cipollone is
testament testimony would be eminently reasonable
and relevant and it's supposedly going to be
happening behind closed doors. Cipollone today
scheduled to be speaking to the House committee.
Whether it happens, we will we will figure that
out. Now, for one moment, I thought, did Trump
mean as a future prisoner rather than as a future
president? That's wishful thinking. I don't expect
that to happen now, a few hours later, just to
kind of close the circle on this insanity, Trump
added some other strange comments in subsequent
posts, also related to the investigations into
him writing quote Both of my phone calls
to Georgia were perfect. Now, of course,
those were the calls where Trump asked for votes.
Speaker 3: I need 11,000 votes. Give me a.
Speaker 2: Break.
Speaker 1: Trump going on and saying I had an
absolute right to make them. And in fact, the
story on the one call was given a retraction or
apology by The Washington Post because they were
given terribly false information about it. Now,
that's not true. And when they heard the actual
call, they realized their story was wrong.
Thank you to The Washington Post. I as
does anyone else just look at the Democrats
have the absolute right to challenge the results
of an election. This one corrupt, rigged and
stolen. Continuing saying, quote, I did nothing
wrong in Georgia, but others did. They cheated in
the 2020 presidential election and those are the
ones that should be investigated and prosecuted.
Letter to follow. And I have not seen the letter
that supposedly follows. This is a desperate,
unhinged man clawing any relevance that he can
obtain. And of course, it's always the opposite.
For six months, he said, the Democrats
are going to try to steal the election.
He tried to steal the election. For months, he
said, the Democrats are going to mess with these
ballots, dumps of ballots and mail in ballots.
And ultimately, it was Trump and his followers
and his lawyers going around the country making
bogus claims about those very mail in ballots.
The allegations are ultimately confessions
with these guys. We've got to be ready for
2022 and we've got to be ready for 2024. Will
we be ready? That's the question. Let me know
what you think. Find me on Twitter at David
Pakman. The David Pakman Show is a viewer
and listener supported program. You can support
us most directly with very few intermediaries
by signing up at. Join pacman dot
com. I would love for you to do that.